jean vincent placé est notre invité le
premier de 2014 bonsoir soirée merci
d'être avec nous pour faire entendre
peut-être votre impatience ou vos
critiques souvent acerbes sauf si bien
sûr vous avez décidé de changer en cette
nouvelle année
vos amis socialistes en tous les cas
rêve d'une bonne résolution de votre
parent jean vincent placé patron des
sénateurs écologistes vous serez
interrogé tout à l'heure par katell
prigent de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire pour preuve par trois avec
dailymotion et puis par perrine tarneaud
de public sénat remet d'abord jean
vincent placé votre avis sur
l'interdiction des spectacles de
dieudonné les mesures se multiplient un
peu partout en france
on va donc d'abord cessé de le qualifier
de comics
est-ce que selon vous la réponse de
manuel valls a été la bonne un nid
comique ni humoriste ni homme de
spectacle en réalité c'est aujourd'hui
un homme politique disons le qui
professent des thèses antisémites qui
sont totalement inacceptables et il fait
plus rire personne sauf effectivement un
public de gens qui sont antisémites et
qui viennent pour cela qu'il retrouve
peut-être bon le côté un peu plus soft
de mai qui se perdent plus tôt dans le
côté un peu plus soft de des meetings
madame le pen et qui retrouve là
peut-être un espace avec des
plaisanteries grasses scandaleuse qui
sont interdites la réponse de manuel
valls et les fermes déterminé
volontariste et est juste et je suis
très content d'ailleurs de pouvoir
soutenir l'action du miz intérieur sur
ce sujet par exemple en matière de
sécurité de la police et de gendarmerie
manuel valls était mise est un
remarquable et sur ce sujet qui est
extrêmement important pour nos pour les
valeurs de la république la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et ça nous fout du
racisme et bien c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir une réponse politique
voilà parce que à un moment bien sûr il
ya un sujet le débat
je leur ai dit que je ne méprise pas
évidemment mais il ya le sujet politique
et un moment dans un pays comme le nôtre
la france avec ses valeurs son
universalisme son attachement
aux droits de l'homme et aux libertés et
bien justement on ne peut pas accepter
de tels propos tenus de meeting en
meeting successifs qui avait déjà
d'ailleurs valu des condamnations à
dieudonné donc vous le répéter manuel
valls est un ministre de l'intérieur
remarquable oui et certains quand même
notamment à l ump lui reproche peut-être
d'être trop bavard sur le dossier dans
d'en faire trop voir d'instrumentaliser
cette affaire il ya une tentation et
version j'ai vu le d'ailleurs changement
réjouit également le soutien d'une
classe politique plutôt unanimes
bien sûr je pense à soi copé j'ai vu
aussi la réponse alain juppé puis
puisque bon voilà la république elle est
là elle nous rassemble 2 c'est que je
dis peu de chose de positif de christian
estrosi met lui aussi à nice à une
position extrêmement déterminé mon ami
le maire de tours le coup socialiste
bruno germain jean germain pardon là une
rue germain ses footballeurs c'est la
rentrée et et à nantes aussi bien sûr on
à laure minervois est ce qu'il n'a pas
le risque de faire de la publicité à
dieudonné parce que vous avez vu quand
même que partout où il devait se
produire
les salles étaient en passe d'afficher
complet il a un public et à public
peut-être nos la curiosité est piquée
mais c'est s'éteint c'est une vraie
question
d'évidence
il en joue monsieur m'bala m'bala a
disons les choses comme ça et ça
devenait cymbales m bala et je vois bien
sûr les réseaux sociaux il a toute une
audience aujourd'hui d'ailleurs sur les
eaux sociaux l'extrême droite est très
très forte elle est très active
on le voit aussi avec les différentes
vidéos qui circulent mais après voilà un
moment dans une prise de position
justement politique eh bien il faut
peser le pour et contre un moment il
faut agir et je le répète l'action de de
manuel valls est tout à fait remarquable
aujourd'hui françois hollande a appelé
donc tous les responsables politiques
les préfets à appliquer la circulaire
valls sur cette interdiction le chef de
l'état que l'on attend la semaine
prochaine pour sa conférence de presse
il va préciser ses intentions une
semaine au chef de l'état quelques
semaines après ses voeux aux français le
31 décembre beaucoup ont reçu
l'intervention du chef de l'état comme
un virage social libéral est ce votre
cas virage non tournant non plus je
trouve que y compris on a eu des
échanges
contradictoires sur le sujet c'est il
assume
il assume en réalité plus nettement en
termes de communication politique à la
politique est menée et vous vous
condamnez je raconte est depuis 18 mois
parce que il y à un équilibre à trouver
sur entre assumer effectivement le
traité européen mais une évidence quand
même beaucoup des stérilités et de
rigueur dans le budget avec une réforme
fiscale qui n'a pas été aboutie donc l'
équilibre entre la volonté de
désendettement que compris nous
partageons dont les écologistes nous
sommes extrêmement attachés à ce que ça
ne soit pas générations futures qui
payent pour les générations présentes
qu'on ne laisse pas des dead s'entasser
qu'il y ait un équilibre entre
endettement déficit mais aussi justice
sociale le redressement du pays
développement économique et notamment un
investissement d'avenir parce que ça
nous y sommes attachés à cet équilibre
là il me semble n'a pas été trouvée dans
les 18 derniers mois donc moi je vois
pas de tournant dans la lettre président
oui je voudrais juste faire en sorte que
dans cette année il y ait cet équilibre
là
bon alors des déficits réduits
endettement nous y sommes tous d'accord
l'attentif cela deux se doit se faire
avec une fiscalité c'est à dire avec des
recettes à mon but jake art qui soit
plus juste les étudiants devraient vous
aider orienter aujourd'hui se mesurera
aux hommes quand vous entendez françois
hollande dire il ya trop d'impôts il ya
trop de dépenses publiques ya trop de
charges sur les entreprises trop de
normes les étouffe ce n est pas cher aux
devoirs
ce qui va être précisément du côté des
actes oui exactement temps du discours
j'attends de voir les ait les précisions
parce que bon ce sont quand même les
termes très généraux ce qui est logique
d'ailleurs pour des voeux présidentiels
-deux sur ce format 9 10 minutes on peut
pas préciser les choses iront à la
conférence de presse mardi prochain
et puis voilà donc à ces dix éléments là
qui sont plutôt constitutifs de son
action depuis 18 mois
vous constaterez également qu'il y à un
élément supplémentaire qui a été pour la
première fois dit par un président la
république intersections et moi je lui
la troisième priorité c'est absolument
pour la première fois envers moi j'avais
eu l'occasion de d'être reçu par le chef
de l'état avant et vous entendu avant
les fêtes
et justement chez v10 mais je pense que
il faut absolument faire en sorte que la
question de la transition énergétique
on va en parler tout à la fois pour les
revenus des ménages les plus modestes
est tout à la fois pour l'emploi écolo
et bien voir ce sont des sujets qui nous
intéressent majoré congrès sur la
dimension budgétaire et économique des
bonnes intentions
oui prêtés à françois hollande oui vous
aviez dit d'abord que le pacte de
compétitivité c'était la goutte d'eau
mais là il parle d'un pacte de
responsabilité et en misant tout sur les
entreprises alors jean vincent placé et
moir dessous par rapport à un propre
citation si j'avais plutôt pas de la tva
pour la goutte d'eau qui d'ailleurs est
partie du pack wii ont financé sont
élancés de crédit d'impôt mérite
effectivement le crédit bureau
d'évidence dans les 20 milliards du
crédit d'impôt qui sont peu utilisés
d'ailleurs et parce que ça veut dire on
n'est pas justement à la montée en
charge est revient demain de nouvelles
baisses de charges pour les entreprises
par exemple vincent placé en est un qui
payant qui paye comme on va trouver
cette fameuse 35 milliards voilà c'est
ça la question c'est le sens de la tente
que j'ai par rapport aux taxes et
comment on va trouver ce financement
si c'est par un financement qui
correspond à la réforme fiscale que nous
voulons de nos propres voeux depuis la
campagne présidentielle avec par exemple
la fusion d'impôt soit revenu et la csg
donc une cg progressive et que ce soit
cette injustice fiscale plus dynamiques
en termes de rendement qui finance voilà
après si ces 35 milliards ce qui a
plutôt été annoncée de ce que j'ai pu
comprendre l'intervention du président
de réduction des dépenses oui mais où 35
milliards on voit déjà la difficulté
pour 12 milliards de réductions de
dépenses
donc là les 35 milliards j'attends de
noir vous vous croyez pas aux marchés
que parce que le medef qui d'ailleurs a
applaudi des deux mains
les voeux du chef de l'état qui disait
si vous baissez nos charges avec 200
milliards d'euros ont pour embaucher un
million de personnes en france ce sont
les deux sujets effectivement de
friction que que nous avons depuis 18
mois c'est à dire que la preuve le
premier élément c'est la vision
austérité rigueur budgétaire qui devait
justement réduire notre endettement et
nos déficits c'est pas tout à fait ça
l'endettement augmente quand même on
doit être à 91 92 % dans de dette
on doit être on devait faire trois pour
cent pour le déficit on est plutôt à 4 1
donc le fait que les rentrées fiscales
ne sont pas là que la croissance ait pas
rendez vous tout cela voilà cesser le
débat qu'on a eu
donc on va pas non plus rester sur le
débat précédent donc il faut se tourner
vers l'avenir donc comment retrouver des
marges de manoeuvre et ses marges de
manoeuvre là je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit de cette façon-là courir autour et
le deuxième élément au delà de l'aspect
budgétaire et fiscale
c'est l'aspect entrepreneurial il a eu
le président la république un accent
très fort mis sur l'aspect
entrepreneuriale ça à la limite sur ce
sujet là moi j'ai pas de problème
particulier parce que j'en suis
évidemment d'accord pour dire que ce
sont les entreprises qui créent l'emploi
dans notre pays
seulement voilà comme justement on le
sait il ya un déficit par exemple de
recherche privée et c'est historique
depuis colbert notre pays ne sait plus
tôt l'investissement public qui produit
la dynamique de l'entreprise privée et
c'est là le problème notamment des
investissements d'avenir et aussi des
financements que que j'ai soutenu
beaucoup d'ailleurs par la banque
publique d'investissement qui a fusionné
plusieurs dispositifs et là nous avons
besoin de retrouver des marges de
manoeuvre pendant tout le débat que je
lis avec l'austérité de rigueur parce
que comment on fait pour trouver les 10
des milliards nécessaires équilibres
pour tout à la fois investissements
d'avenir plus écolo sur leur transport
sur le numérique 60 et sur
l'agroalimentaire c'est ce qui avait été
dit par le premier jean marc ayrault
notamment à à l'été 2013
et effectivement les financements
entreprises pme bons amis et ça ça
m'intéresse à leur combat corps ça vous
intéresse on vous écoute je vous posais
des questions oui j'espère que j'aurai
des réponses précises posées beaucoup
des chefs de l'état lors de sa
conférence de presse soulignant la
transition énergétique
mais c'est toute la deuxième partie
rassuré bouge enfin se passer je vous
écoute je me dis que vraiment françois
hollande il va avoir du mal à passer aux
actes avec une majorité comme la sienne
avec vous évidemment pour assumer cette
nouvelle stratégie pragmatique mais la
stratégie pragmatique je vous dis pour
moi n'est pas nouvelle et on a déjà
depuis 18 mois et je boude mise beaucoup
sur initiative politique ou la scène
vous l'avait condamné à 18 mois elle est
renforcée mais il faut pas compter sur
vous quoi il est président la république
c'est lui qui fixe le cap nous - je suis
président d'un groupe parlementaire
écologiste on est dans la majorité
et on a un gouvernement et elle avait
trouvé des propositions et des
gouvernements et deux ministres qui sont
particulièrement utiles et nous posons
sur des choix ne pesons sur la
contribution climat énergie
nous avons pesé on le verra sur la
transition énergétique avec la fermeture
de fessenheim et l'orientation de 75 à
50% pour la production d'électricité par
voie nucléaire donc il ya beaucoup de
sujets sur lesquels nous sommes actifs
nous avons quand même réussi à fait en
sorte que nous protégions le pays du
d'un risque environnemental majeur c'est
à dire avec caisson et 15 de schiste un
sens des écologistes au gouvernement il
y aurait aujourd'hui des puits de gaz de
schiste sur le territoire national en
seine-et-marne dans le gard dans
l'aveyron voilà il ya la loi
d'interdiction avait été votée avant la
fin sans précédent ce pays
les lobbys productiviste et
énergétique est plutôt anti colo sont
très très très très très fort et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes quelque
part et au gouvernement et dans les
institutions un rempart par rapport à
ces lobbys et ça c'est une fierté qu'on
peut avoir après on apprenait on pas à
ses deux victoires écologie c'est pour
ça que nous portons le débat sur des
sujets qui préoccupent et transition
énergie il revient emploi écolo façon
thermique des bâtiments transports
collectifs voilà une autre
un autre monde ça veut dire un autre
mois économique nous voulons avoir des
revenir justement je voudrais savoir si
vous êtes passablement énervé par la
volonté de passer par des ordonnances
pour aller plus vite sur certains
dossiers notamment la simplification
administrative est ce que vous allez tu
réduis sans broncher ça m'étonnerait
l'assaut rôle de pacification
administrative c'est c'est très bien ça
c'est d'ailleurs ça fait 30 ans qu'on le
dit dans dans ce pays le poids de
l'administration centrale moi c'est un
des sujets j'avais abordé avec le chef
de l'état avant avant l'été la valeur
les ordres d'un enfer généphi c'est à
dire la question la question de la
réforme de l'état est un des grands
thèmes par exemple de michel rocard
quand il était à matignon de lieux et
jeux spécialement t'as pas été à mon
avis assez envisagé dans ce quinquennat
c'est d'ailleurs à mon avis dans la
réforme de l'administration centrale qu
on pourrait plutôt trouver les économies
donc vous voyez ce qu'on cherche des
économies à faire le pas vrai qu'on a
dit ça la simplification c'est plutôt
positif
si la simplification ça veut pas dire la
réduction des droits des travailleurs ou
alors la réduction de telles ou telles
normes environnementales qui protège
notre nature où notre environnement
et bien ça c'est ça n'irait pas mais
simplifier pour être plus efficace
notamment dans la création d'entreprises
dans la fusion d'entreprises en
l'acquisition c'est très bien mais
pourquoi les ordonnances parce que en
réalité dans un pays comme le nôtre
et quelque part je crois que les
mouvements sociaux qui ont eu lieu
nombreux lourd et parfois même quelques
révolte disons le
à la fin de l'année 2013 eh bien je
crois que quand on veut aller vite
peut-être par exemple le sujet et qu'au
talent quand on abordera également bien
voit qu'à la fin ça bloque et donc moi
je ne crois pas aux ordonnances d'une
part peut-être de façon un peu
idéologique c'est vrai par rapport au
rôle du parlement mais aussi parce que
c'est justement ce n'est pas efficace et
on ne va pas plus vite en réalité
condamné ce choix qui a été beaucoup le
vin condamner notre maintien depuis le
début de cette émission vous montrez que
vous avez peut-être pris de bonnes
résolutions pour 2014
jean vincent placé vous semblez le
confirmer en opinant mais c'est vrai
j'ai bien vous aussi de faire c'est très
important
c'est l'humanisme également une chanson
aussi c'est chaque année d'essayer
s'améliorer moi je réussis pas toujours
toutes les années mais le sud partie en
effet des bonnes résolutions à l'avant
que moins vindicatifs avec vos amis
manifeste pour propositionnelle aussi à
travers voilà c'est dit c'est clairement
dit dans les cas lors de ses voeux vous
l'avez rappelé françois hollande va
présenter la transition énergétique
comme l'une de ses trois décisions
majeures cette priorité
trois priorités avec cache en fait ces
bonnes intentions on voit tout de suite
ça avec mounir souci avant d'accueillir
katell prigent de l' agence
france-presse
2014 année de vérité sur le fond de
l'écologie en tout cas cette fois c'est
promis
fini les discours place aux actes
françois hollande la firme dans ses
voeux la révolution verte c'est
maintenant je veux que notre pays a
accompli sa transition énergétique avec
un calendrier déjà fixée le projet doit
doit arriver au parlement après des
municipales et la majorité socialiste
prévient elle ne se laissera pas débordé
par ses partenaires
je ne considère pas question d'écologie
soit l'objet de discussions avec nos
alliés d'europe écologie les verts
je suis très heureuse que
la formation politique participe au
gouvernement et à la majorité mais ils
ne sont pas porteurs exclusive des
questions d'écologie
le chantier est immense avec notamment
l'objectif de réduire la consommation
énergétique de moitié d'ici à 2050 et de
mettre en place une fiscalité écologique
cohérente
un agenda ambitieux qui fera forcément
beaucoup de déçus selon cet ancien
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie mais je
crois pas une seconde dans la parole
présidentielle
dire que le problème qu'on a avec ce
gouvernement et ce président sur la
question écologique c'est que depuis
presque deux ans maintenant tout n'est
que mensonges et trahisons on a un
discours très ambitieux sur lequel à la
limite il ya pas grand chose d'ailleurs
à redire qui très très séduisant et puis
on a une réalité et des actes qui sont
en contradiction totale suspension de
l'écotaxe recul sur la taxation du
diesel
autant de dossiers en suspens qui vont
polluer le travail du gouvernement cette
année un gouvernement attendu au
tournant par les ong
irrité par les hésitations au sommet de
l'état la vraie question
ça va être le niveau d'investissement si
quelque chose est prioritaire ça doit se
voir pour que ça se voit ça doit se voir
avec une mobilisation de moyens
combien l'état va mettre sur la table
pour la transition énergétique pour le
président une enveloppe annuelle de 20
milliards d'euros sera nécessaire pour
financer la transition énergétique
une manne qui représente quatre fois le
budget du ministère de l'agriculture
voilà donc ça coûte cher à la transition
énergétique kat et delage 40 ans ça
coûte très très cher et c'est plutôt
centaines de milliards d'euros
d'investissements qui ont été mis dans
le nucléaire
tant que ça ne s'est pas tout à fait
comparable en terme de
d'échelle bien entendu chantal jouanno
qui parle de mensonges et trahisons pour
françois hollande elle ne croit pas du
tout on ses promesses de transition
écologique pour 2014 est ce que vous y
croyez
mais je vais y croire oui bien sûr le
président de la république pour la
première fois jeudi pour la première
fois un présent dans la pluie la vème
république qui dit que sa priorité une
de ses trois priorités
cette année c'est la transition
écologique et nous allons avoir à
transition énergétique avec la loi sur
le sujet avant l'été le premier ministre
s'y est engagé c'était annoncé la
conférence environnementale en septembre
y compris par le président ça va être un
énorme chamboulement
et c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
laquelle nous participons à ce
gouvernement c'est parce que nous avons
conclu avec le président de la
république un accord politique en effet
sur la réduction de 75 à 50% de
production d'électricité par voir
nucléaire nous volonté de réduire la
consommation énergétique des volontés de
relance et les politiques en particulier
public d'ailleurs vis-à-vis des énergies
renouvelables donc ça sera un vrai sujet
parce qu'effectivement est bon d'en
parler avec michel grossiord combien
d'argent avec bpi je dédie avec quels
outils de quel montant sur quels
investissements les un responsable
international dit chiche
oui je prends le président au mot mais
il faut des actes lindigo l'audience on
a quand même l'impression que ça fait
déjà un nom vous dit au président il
faut un cap il faut des actes il faut
est ce que on repart dans un cycle 2 on
demande au président un cap ont demandé
à clé et on attend non je pense que là
il y a une volonté de part et d'autre
d'ailleurs je fais grosseur avec sa
subtilité habituel ça a souligné le ton
peut être critique automatismes ont
écouté je serai une présent a pu lui
donc avant avant les fêtes
on a eu des discussions de nombreuses
avec le premier ministre le hi fi de
martin régulièrement avec pierre
moscovici enfin bernard cazeneuve
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui ces
problèmes ce qui a péché dans les 18
premiers mois on est allé très très vite
dans les habitudes de la vème république
le pouvoir exécutif
on a à peu près tous les pouvoirs sur la
vème république on est président et
premier ministre le gouvernement
et hop on déroule une politique qu'on a
à priori déroulé justement pendant la
campagne présidentielle et on voit les
priorités qui ont été menées et je fais
toujours dit les priorités des 18
derniers mois quand incontestablement
pas été très écologique là et c'est pas
je crois seulement l'effet de notre
pression politique c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya une prise en compte des
problématiques de la planète de souci
sincère de trouver l'équilibré entre le
développement et l'écologie et o'shea
j'espère qu'il ya une prise de
conscience sur la préparation de la
conférence climat de 2015 qui sera libre
en france donc ça c'est extrêmement
important et donc dire que 2014 en
france il ya cette transition écologique
va se mettre en place avec la loi de
transition énergétique avec aussi la
loi-cadre soit biodiversité d'ailleurs
en ça n'a pas été tellement cité depuis
quelques semaines et donc comme je vois
les différents responsables dans les
jours à venir je reviendrai la charge
sur ce sujet et vous l'avez compris
aussi en terme de débats et de
discussions de la majorité parlementaire
notamment dans le cas de la préparation
du budget tous subi tout à la fois le
plf et plfss
moi je souhaite avoir une discussion en
amont chez dia bernard cazals très
précisément on ne peut plus accepter
effectivement on fasse les lettres
blanches et d'ailleurs pour le coup des
budgets que ensuite il n'y a pas de
discussion réelle sera la réforme
fiscale et puis on nous fasse voter des
budgets comme ça tu étais le faire
c'était clair depuis deux ans c'est pas
un peu trop tard que vous ne commencez
pas vous les écologistes a commencé à le
payer c'est à dire avec lui des i qui
vient un petit peu marcher sur l'eau
bêtement en demandant des écologistes va
venir les écologistes du centre la route
ou goût nouvelle donne qui m'a déjà été
rejoints
par madame athar qui vous a quitté jean
teulé déçu déçu des verts au
gouvernement qui finissent pas
s'éparpiller et est ce que pour les
experts sont terrorisés par les hordes
de nouveaux écologistes que nous
indiquait été fêté par nos militants ont
trois premiers des travaux plus
sérieusement nous avons nous à nous
avons une période qui est difficile qui
correspond à temps difficiles pour la
planète qui attend difficile pour
l'europe un temps difficile pour le pays
en temps difficiles pour la majorité on
est dans un gouvernement il est prolongé
plus facile d'être à côté du
gouvernement de faire mélenchon de de
critiquer tout et encore on va pas te
tellement le débouché bon les centristes
m'ont ils sont centristes
voilà madame jouanno a été ministre de
l'écologie de ce sarkozy dans le monde
je suis désolé mon façon les bills ans à
peu près comment il ya beaucoup de
maîtrise
le bilan du grenelle de l'environnement
est supérieur à ce qu'a fait la gauche
depuis 18 mois me gillot même moi je lis
le bilan de 2007-2009 2-0 d'état qui
grenelle 1 a été très bon c'était il ya
eu 240 préconisations aucune n'a été
mise en place et le président la
république nicolas sarkozy après les
régionales de 2010 a dit maintenant ça
suffit
l'écologie j'en ai marre et madame
jouanno était là madame kosciusko
morizet ou si on la cite pas mais était
là pour que ce ne sont pas eux qui vont
nous donner des leçons au plus bas
monsieur la route eurobonds lui c'est le
spécialiste des nouveaux marty tous les
trois ans bon voilà vous avez quand même
dans le reportage à l'instant de mounir
souci c'est pas vous les verts qu'elle
est forcément leader sur le dossier
énergétique va transition en train de
perdre les socialistes seront à la
traîne du combat sais pas j'espère mais
nous alors là je veux dire très
sincèrement si un jour il ya plus besoin
d'un parti écologiste pour porter
l'écologie ça m'ira très bien c'est pas
le problème nous on veut justement que
on protège la planète on lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique qu'on fasse
attention à la biodiversité
on change de modèle agro alimentaire et
qu'il y ait une autre vision de
transition énergétique et on pense que
c'est bien pour d'une part les revenus
et les dépenses des ménages et on pense
que c'est bien pour l'emploi donc c'est
ce sont les idées comporte après quand
on a dit ça si laurence rossignol est
très sincère valait 7 et secrétaires
nationales l'environnement du social icf
un travail remarquable on a beaucoup
travaillé quelque temps le cadre de
l'accord politique nous avons passé pour
les législatives physique partager bon
espoir qu'ils le disent eux qui prennent
ça en charge directement voilà alors
dans le cadre de ces nouveaux
accommodements gens visés entre les
socialistes et les réductions la part du
nucléaire oui réduction la consommation
énergétique il faut vraiment qu'on
incite non il faut wittenheim doit-elle
fermé mais objet de la loi c'est à dire
que par exemple j'ai eu une discussion
avec henri proglio pdg d'edf et lui
dis-je appliquerait la loi ce qui est
plutôt bien pour le pdg d'edf et donc
ils font pour très simplement parce
qu'on connaît ses convictions sur le
nucléaire puis à la limite c'est son
problème
parce que il doit puisque il est
président directeur général d'edf obéir
la puissance publique et par le
gouvernement tout gouvernement doit
faire des propositions le parlement doit
attaquer alors ses trajectoires et
cohérente
d'ici 2025 de réduction de la part du
nucléaire et donc effectivement commencé
par fermer des centrales et des
réacteurs est évidemment sur fessenheim
c'est un vrai enjeu tout en laissant le
père et sa ville aient pas encore
ouverts le père il a déjà triplé ça vous
allait bien pris plus de volume non mais
il a triplé de deux coups depuis le
début et les délais ils gagneront
également été multiplié par 3 donc
j'attends de voir ce qu'il en sera moi
j'ai toujours dit qu'il ne serait pas
opérationnel pendant le quinquennat et
j'ai quand même l'impression que les
faits me donnent raison
avant d'avoir des autres sujets qu'ils
atteignent une question est ce que dans
le capot de ces nouveaux jacquot
vainement entre les socialistes et les
verts se remirent d'autres dans les
détails est ce que vous êtes prêts
l'aéroport notre dame est
en heure je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire des petits accommodements c'est que
à un moment lorsqu'on réussit à
convaincre politiquement sur le fond et
que le présent un public dit une de mes
priorités 2014 c'est la transition
écologique et bien c'est pas un premier
commandement c'est pour le coup là un
virage politique
vous voyez plutôt indiquer chez vous
dire on va se dire même la vérité
oui je suis frappé de voir à quel point
toute la presse notamment économiques
patronales ou disons un peu orienté de
droite politique
ça a mis énormément l'accent sur le
virage social libéral c'est en faisant
des tonnes est pas une ligne sur la
transition écologique non flottement non
plus à la transition écologique dans le
discours quand même plus sur le jeu
l'appétit cas cette presse et ses médias
pour tout ce qui rapproche d'un
libéralisme et qu'il souhaite plutôt que
d'un sujet énergétique lourd qui est
visée effectivement à des
réglementations d'une phrase du
président qui effectivement n'a pas
développé ce cas on attend sa conférence
de presse - tous les cas jaurès en place
et qu'elle est convaincue janvier
rendez-vous quelque part j'ai envie non
je n'ai même pas j'en suis convaincu
c'est que je m'en réjouis voilà je
voulais en effet déjà fait avec le
présent à zurich effets dans la crise
écologique
une de ses priorités dans un mini est un
grand virage vous estimez donc
le projet de l'aéroport notre dame des
landes ne peut pas voir le jour oui si
on vous dit ça depuis le début je crois
que l'on convainc ouvrant moi je n'avais
pas l'impression que ça avance beaucoup
il ya des le préfet le préfet fait son
travail il a pris des arrêtés n'ont fait
au courant continu le débat par rapport
à l'emprise par rapport aux zones
humides par rapport à la biodiversité
par rapport au problème de la politique
de l'eau on continue combat et
d'ailleurs nous serons je serai le 22
février à la mobilisation à la
mobilisation sur place et voyez on a
tous types de renforts on a même les
bonnets rouges
je ne sais pas si nous on fera les beaux
nevers tu feras assez beau je n'ai pas
besoin de bonnes et voilà les bonnets
rouges et l'écotaxe toujours emmanuel
cau soit de secrétaire national 10 qui
fait et je m'en réjouis un très très bon
début et notre patronne du parti
emmanuelle cosse bien juste révélé
qu'elle était élu voilà elle dit aussi
que l'écotaxe sera mise en place en 2014
à lille 3 oui vous avez des assurances
du chef de l'état aucune date n'a été
fixée entre contrats signés on va finir
on va bientôt pénalité il ya le pdg d
comme auch qui vient demain au sénat où
le savez avec la commission d'enquêté a
été mis en place auquel commis son
enquête il ya des réflexions des
renégociations
moi j'espère que l'écotaxe sera mise en
place avant l'été avant l'été instruit
c'est mon souhait parce qu'on en est à
parler de taxe d'argent parlons des
contraventions et des pv où en êtes vous
de vos remboursements de ses dix-huit
mille euros
de pv un pays qui est réglé l'ensemble
du dossier vous avez tout rembourser
tout régler échelonné ce que vous avez
compris que les gens aient été choquées
par ouï par le fait que j'ai dit dans
une émission avant les fêtes et y allant
bien sûr nation je comprends mais pas
m'appesantir sur les circonstances avant
2010 quatre ans maintenant des mauvaises
habitudes
évidemment injustifiable inexcusable je
les dis je même présenté des excuses gpi
voilà vous estimez que cette ardoise
d'inhumer l'heureux a pu être
instrumentalisée par certaines grosses
amis ennemis politiques
ça vient du conseil régional concerne
aussi or comme vous êtes bien informé
vous connaissez les réponses aux
questions posées et je suis assez gentil
pour prendre tout ça sans moi voilà
d'accord très bientôt les cas vous avez
fait votre mea culpa ray vous ferez
attention dorénavant avec cette vitesse
je fais attention au classement pour
continuer une petite question encore
peut-être sur les municipales et les
scrutins qui s'annonce je vais également
les européennes où l'année les sondages
sont pas très favorables pour les verts
et non non je vous disais tout à l'heure
vous les tenez municipal pour que vous
dites que c'est pas falloir un peu de
mesure parce que pour les municipales on
est dans la plupart des grandes villes
présent paris lyon toulouse nantes
strasbourg lille on est crédité entre 7
et 12 % qui sont des scores
particulièrement honorable celle pour
les européennes oui donc des belles
choses engins étaient aux municipales
l'hypnose et de fiom oui après bon
alors mais c'est un vrai sujet c'est à
dire que quand on est à une élection
européenne qui ne passionne pas beaucoup
les français où c'est très difficile
d'animer le débat dans une situation en
plus la question européenne aujourd'hui
et quand même fortement contestée parce
qu elle s apparente justement tellement
libéralisme que c'est compliqué pour un
parti comme le nôtre extrêmement
fédéraliste de porter l'idée européenne
et bien c'est vrai que quand 100 la
fouille l enthousiasme daniel cohn
bendit c'est évidemment un vrai manque
est plus dur c'est comme je le dis
souvent l'équipe de france sans zidane
ça marche vous en viendrez vous manquera
zilon pour ce scrutin
des hommes et merci keitel péri dans le
public sénat va arriver maintenant jean
vincent placé avant ça on va voir
comment vous avez beaucoup chauffer les
oreilles de vos amis politiques
pas seulement socialistes d'ailleurs au
cours de l'année écoulée mais là on a
bien compris que vous avez décidé je
peux dire que vous rentrer dans le rang
parce que vous allez me reprendre en
tous les cas vous avez affiché ici même
vous pouvez les résolutions pour l'année
nouvelle
mounir souci jean vincent placé
c'est l'homme que l'on adore détester il
provoque et attire les critiques y
compris à gauche lors de la sphère
leonarda il demande aux lycéens de
descendre dans la rue
les socialistes s'indigne au ps on
l'accuse de toujours taper pour amuser
la galerie françois rebsamen vont en lui
un garçon sympathique qui ne peut
s'empêcher de dire des conneries chaque
semaine pas facile
la cohabitation entre les verts et les
socialistes chez des partenaires qui
parfois sont agaçants sont à lui à 100
pour la majorité mais sur agaçant pour
eux même s'ils se regarde bien je les
appelle pour eux d'ailleurs pour nous
pour la gauche a retrouvé leurs esprits
et être unis celui qui voulait être
ministre ne rate pas une occasion de
taper sur l'exécutif et ça énerve
jean vincent est quelqu'un de
d'agréables mais quelqu'un qui est
capable de sortir une pointe une attaque
en règle
or que finalement il le fait par pure
tactique une tactique qui agace aussi
les siens beaucoup voient derrière les
critiques récurrentes de jean vincent
placé une trop grande ambition
personnelle car trop vouloir faire
entendre sa voix peut aussi brouiller le
message politique
je pense qu'il ya une forme d'une
maturité à alimenter en permanence la
polémique
finalement les pics les plus acerbes
viennent de son propre camp en privé ses
amis assure que la seule ligne de jean
vincent placé c'est le pouvoir bien plus
importants que les idées voilà donc ce
que sandra cirque arts a pu recueillir
sur tous complices seront et qu'il va
falloir donc réviser un petit peu
orienté quand même à écouter logique du
genre j'ai remarqué que j'avais quelques
amis qui de temps en temps été
interviewés qui m'ont dit c'est on est
sûr de ne pas passer lorsqu'on a dit du
bien de toi j'ai les noms
particulièrement rire mais c'est vrai ce
qui ressort des gens qu'on va
interviewer c'est le côté un peu
personnel ambitieux plutôt que les idées
j'ai toujours assumé ces trois là je ne
sais pas
la politique sans ambition je vois ça
barde d'une partie l'a fait sans
ambition déjà pour ses idées ses
politiques publiques à mettre en place
et puis de fait à un moment aussi que si
on demande le suffrage des électeurs
c'est qu'on pense qu'on est un petit peu
capable de faire en sorte de se
récupérer des autres tant que c'est pas
nul non plus et moi je vais vous dire je
fais surtout la politique sans
hypocrisie
contrairement à d'autres lui d'ajouter
chien bien sûr bien sûr mais peut-être
ce qui gêne les gens c'est l'autre a dit
non ouais peut-être qu'ils ce qui gêne
les autres personnalités dans le monde
politique c'est cette façon vous avez de
deux de vous promener dans ce monde
politique avec un air détaché dans le
style rien le matin et donc finalement
on ne sait pas si c'est une posture où
c'est le vrai jean vincent placé
moi je suis ou dire très franchement je
suis pas sûr que l'objectif de vie
politique
ça soit de montrer ses états d'âme ou ou
de dire qu'on doute
bon j'ai compris que maintenant on était
très dans le prix très introspectif
donc je suis pas tenir de grands
discours de savoir ce que les uns les
autres auraient fait en 40 ou en 58 80
et c est un moment je pense qu'un
responsable politique ce doit être
quelqu'un qui est clair dans sa tête
quoi qu'elle dise que vous ayez fendre
qui voulait mettre en place fait
l'impression qu'on a depuis le début de
cette émission ode au delà de ce virage
que vous avez évoqué le voyage du chef
de l'état sur les dossiers énergétiques
notamment
vous avez peut être envie que le regard
sur vous change je vais vous le dire je
suis persuadé que si j'avais un
communicant ce qui n'est pas le cas il
me dirait à ce moment est foutue
répondent oui et c'est important et
cetera non moi je leur égard non mais
c'est vrai je ne vous cache pas que ce
qui m'intéresse c'est vraiment de faire
des choses quoi porter les idées
vous avez peut-être envie de servir une
autre côté vous en avais un peu marre
qu'on se met nu un peu dur de la
politique ou les choses n'avancent pas
forcément comme vous le souhaitez ça
c'est un
c'est un vrai débat sert qu'à un moment
c'est vrai que l'on peut raisonnablement
se poser la question en 2014 justement
dans la vie politique c est ce que c'est
dans le champ politique ont fait le plus
avancé aussi l'idée de voir par exemple
nicolas hulot bon même s'il a quand même
une souci à la fin de de leur entrée
aussi même si on n'est pas rentré très
longtemps dans le champ politique ça
c'est un vrai débat se comporte plus
avec une ong s comporte plus dans des
agences de communication et ce qu'on
perde plus moi j'ai toujours eu cette
tentation de venise parce que j'ai
c'était un tacle était utilisé par alain
juppé lorsqu'il a évolué un peu celle
décrochée dans la vie politique et au
fond je pense qu à titre personnel
aujourd'hui je pourrais faire beaucoup
d'autres choses je sais de prétention de
pouvoir dire ça je crois en revanche et
c'est le vrai sujet d'ailleurs de
l'écologie politique et du fait partie
des ré du fait aussi effectivement qu'on
s'occupe d'un appareil politique et
c'est à ce qu'on trouve tout à fait
normal par exemple pour françois
hollande
mais qu'on trouve choquant pour les
verts c'est ça que chi chi chi le propre
des verts s'est d'ailleurs y compris
c'est logique qu'on subisse parfois
quelques sarcasmes condamne tonnes en a
tellement donner de leçons sur la
politique autrement et selectra on
réalité on l'a fait plutôt vraiment
parce que c'est ça qui est important
pas forcément comme les autres je le dis
toujours parce que justement nous pour
le coup ces instruments sur sur les
questions notamment des heureux
financièrement on n'a jamais eu de liens
avec des entreprises ou des choses comme
ça on est très attaché au cumul des
mandats on a toujours mis en avant la
parité depuis très longtemps voilà il ya
eu 2000 one et cécile duflot il ya
emmanuelle cosse donc on fait quand même
d'un politique différemment voilà il
faut maintenant la faire vraiment et
après tout on est content il impose
quand on a comme nom mais ça ça vous
aussi vos ambitions
mais non mais c'est même pas ça c'est
que l'histoire des postes vous êtes
journaliste je suis sûr qu'un jour
voudrais avoir plus d'audience encore
comme journaliste et parce que pousser
là je mange en aller si vous saviez vous
qu utile
rentré dans le prochain long gelé dit
plusieurs fois dans différents supports
qui effectivement j'avais un petit peu
couru après ça allait notamment dit oui
oui mais c'est sans détour je sais pas
c'est si vous développez autorise
perrine tarneaud sur d'autres champs
d'activité sur ses produits elle a déjà
pour le gorille
je quelque part et je le dis avec en
plus le respect que j'ai réellement pour
ceux ci du foot pascal canfin qui font
un vrai boulot - ton ma part je pense
que j'ai trouvé un lieu d'affluence avec
la présence de ce groupe parlementaire
où je crois je suis assez reconnus et je
pense que je suis très bien où je suis
comme vous vous êtes entretenu il ya
quelques semaines avec françois hollande
est ce qu'il a trouvé les mots et parce
qu'il a fait appel à son sens de
l'humour pour vous rappeler que vous
étiez peut-être allé trop loin que vous
alliez lancer le bouchon trop loin
parfois oh c'est pas du tout le genre du
chef de l'état est d'ailleurs direct
alors non mais titre on est vraiment une
très bonne discussion de plus d'une
heure sur la voie non mais attends je
suis désolé 1,2 alors on a quand même
parlé à saint-affrique on a parlé de
série on a parlé de l'europe à boma par
la situation
c'est terrible de dire ce que vous venez
de dire si je viens de vous parler pas
de voilà qu'on a parlé la politique de
colonnades des différents sujets que
vous avez abordé
j'ai parlé d'elle forme institutionnelle
j'ai même par les siens vraiment parler
parler de réformes institutionnelles et
même proportionnelle j'ai parlé de
référer à l étage par la réforme de
décentralisation qui n'est pas allé
assez loin notamment sur la loi
métropole moi je suis pas suppression
des conseillers généraux bout d un
moment et on n'a pas parlé et le sujet
décentralisation a également été relevé
par le chaton et j'ai évidemment parler
de l'écologie la transition écologique
et puis nous avons aussi aborder les
échéances à venir c'est bien avec
naturellement trois questions
d'actualité pour terminer les missions
léonard bas qui ne reviendra sans doute
pas en france en tout cas si les
conclusions du rapporteur public les
conclusions du rapporteur public
interviendra sans plus à 4 ans 19% voilà
du cg sur celui qui suit son cours c'est
le droit qui dit je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire vous reconnaissez
aujourd'hui avoir un peu dérapé après
avoir appelé les jeunes à manifester
non je n'ai pas appelé manifesté j'ai
entendu j'ai ouï mais non c'est un
malentendu et je vous remercie
d'ailleurs la sp et la journaliste
précédentes qui étaient là parce que
j'avais soutenu la mobilisation
étudiante soutenu à vocation étudiante
s'était d'ailleurs le communiqué de
presse du parti de pascal durand notre
secrétaire national et par un petit
effet sémantique au bout de trois heures
c'est devenu après la dépêche
un appel à la mobilisation lycéenne je
vais vous dire les choses très
clairement
moi je soutenais leonarda après vu le
bruit que ça a fait et disons la
compréhension que ça suscite et et bien
je lui dis aujourd'hui je ne renierai
pas les choses dans les mêmes termes
c'est clair voilà une jean-vincent placé
le bureau du sénat statut demain sur la
demande de levée d'immunité
parlementaire du sénateur serge dassault
la justice le demande
est ce que le sénat doit aller dans son
sens moi je vais vous dire aussi très
franchement les choses le l'immunité
parlementaire c'est un sujet important
qui a été mis en place un autre et
période où justement vous les protégez
les parlementaires par rapport aux
pouvoirs du roi au pouvoir de justice
d'ailleurs le roi de saisie physique des
parlementaires et ça a perduré soirée
publique dont c'est quelque chose
d'important temps sur les
responsabilités que sur la viabilité
même s'il ya eu et c'est bien logique
des réformes qui ont tenu compte de la
situation moderne et y compris dernière
du fait que nous soyons dans des
républiques et il ya en revanche après
cet élément de principe je pense est
important il ya un autre élément qui est
comme l'ours au plan du principe c'est
toute la procédure est soumise au secret
d'instruction c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui moi je ne connais pas animé
de parlementaires le bureau design situé
devant lui sur la forme et non sur le
fond ils sont sur la forme de la requête
du procureur il va y avoir un vice
président qui est jean léonce dupont qui
reste qu'il faut laisser la justice
hier j'ai un vice président qui
s'appelle jean nord du pont qui va
rapporter demain devant le bureau du
sénat et le rapport et les délibérations
et le résultat sont soumis au secret
d'instruction donc vous ne m'en voudrez
pas de ne pas épiloguer ce sujet moi ce
que je souhaite
ce que je souhaite c'est que on vérifie
que tous les moyens sont donnés à la
justice pour agir
voilà le sens qui doit être très clair
de la décision qui doit donc s donnant
levée de l'immunité parlementaire et du
rapport et la discussion qui aura lieu
demain et si j'étais au sénat même
concernant sa non chez les femmes âgées
non non c'est bien de dire ça mais moi
je dis la même chose à chaque fois jeudi
pour me d'ailleurs quand on est dans
l'opposition de la majorité je dis moi
la même chose à dire que quand il ya eu
le woerth bettencourt sarkozy j'ai dit
la même chose qu'en gt2 rare de
l'opposition j'ai même dit la même chose
pour jérôme cahuzac
ça m'a été reproché par mes propres amis
secret d'instruction séparation des
pouvoirs et le juge
eh bien il fait son travail très bien on
attend la décision du bureau du sénat
sachant que des groupes comme le parti
communiste par exemple nous demander la
levée de l'immunité parlementaire on a
entendu effectivement votre position
jamais remplacer merci d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui merci à perrine fou à
la semaine prochaine